there's some sort of political
legitimacy
to someone's name being on tv or in the
headline
all day long i mean it happened it's
happened with trump where it's like most
people aren't paying attention because
there's so many things going on and so
trump's in the headlines all day long
what's your natural reaction if you're
not paying attention trump must be the
front-runner for president or must be a
serious contender and that's how it
works
i think a lot of folks in media
looking back now they have regrets about
the way they handled trump
in 2016 and a few a few people have
actually said as much publicly
but i also think that those same people
especially on the television side of
things
this has been the most remarkable run
for them financially and ratings wise
that they've ever had you know and so
and so how bad do they really feel about
it because
this has been sort of a golden era for
them and and and it's a really hard
thing to sort of grapple with
the fact the fact that on the one hand
we probably did not
operate we the media did not operate in
a
in a really respectable ethical way in
covering trump's rise
um and yet uh trump has been
just incredibly lucrative for the media
industry on the whole
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks limited
series on the future of i'm your host
zach rauman
today is thursday april 22nd 2021
we are talking about the future of
political media with tim alberta
the former chief political correspondent
at politico and is now moving
to be a lead writer at the atlantic
before we dive in
big news that happened this week that i
think is worth addressing i don't do a
lot of
news updates on this type of episode but
it's important to talk about
the trial of derek chauvin the verdict
is in
the cop that was accused of murdering
george floyd
and sparked some really important
conversations and mass protests around
the country
he was found guilty on tuesday april
20th
and i think it's important we say this
that this is a good thing this is a good
moment um
a man who murdered someone
while having a badge and a gun
who was meant to serve and protect that
human um
is going to jail and look there are a
lot of problems in this country
a lot of problems in this country and we
are nowhere near
close enough to where we need to be on a
whole host of issues specifically racial
justice
but i will say it's good to know when
the when all the eyes are on
something like this it is a good thing
to see justice served so we have a long
way to go
but i hope this brings a sense of hope
and renewal and um
relief for many folks from millions
around the country we have a long way to
go
um saying prayers for the families of
the floyd family and and all of the
families and
individuals affected by this trial and
it's good to see justice served
um with that
i think it's fitting the talk because
the political press
and press in general have covered this
trial in so many different ways and i'm
excited
to bring on tim alberta from politico
today or formerly from politico and we
caught him in this awkward
to me awesome transition between uh his
new job at the atlantic magazine
and his former job as chief political
correspondent at politico but he covered
us on the trail
when we ran for president um i got to
know him then he has this
he's from michigan um and i think he was
recording this from michigan
um and so he has this middle of the
middle of the country
perspective i think he covers the right
and the left really well
um and he covered andrew well he
understood
being from the midwest why he was
resonating with millions of americans um
and to top it off the reason this
episode is also great is carly riley
is back so i think i say this to tim but
i was excited to do this episode because
it's a topic that we actually have
we being carly and i have experience in
or some experience in um and navigating
politics in the media
so it's a it's a fascinating episode
about how the media works
why andrew was covered in certain ways
why he wasn't covered in certain ways
why certain narratives emerge out of our
political press and where this
type of divisiveness
in the political press where it's going
where political parties are going tim is
a fascinating
brilliant individual it was exciting to
chat with him i know you're going to
enjoy it so tune in
to our limited series the future of
political media
with tim alberta carly riley here on
yang speaks
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks i am so
excited we're going to talk about the
future of politics and the reason this
is exciting because we've talked about a
lot of
futuristic topics that myself and carly
know very little about or have done
let's call it a week of research on and
that's about it but this one we actually
have some legs to stand on because we
have familiarity
and experience in politics and the media
but we've brought on
uh someone i've looked up to and gotten
to know on the presidential trail
because i just think the way he writes
cuts through in a certain clarity
and a certain independence that i
thought was missing um
in political media so tim alberta has
joined us
who's the former chief political
correspondent um at politico
welcome to the show welcome young speaks
it is great to be here guys this is fun
and uh the last time i saw you zach was
when we were
jumping off the bus in uh in des moines
on caucus night
and uh that seems like quite literally a
lifetime ago
before you know pre-covered pre-election
pre-everything right like that that was
a that was a
different world we were living in back
then so we
um we did this thing tim i remember
texting me he's like hey i want to do
this kind of crazy idea like can i
follow along
on caucus day not night caucus day
and then into the night um just to sense
like the tensions and what
candidates are doing and come riding on
the bus and i remember talking to andrew
i was like look i trust him
um if you're okay he was still kind of
sick he was recovering but he's like
let's do it
and so tim got the just all access pass
if you will um and the piece i thought
was
was um was great and you were fair to us
which which i
respect um so so thank you good to see
you again
um here's what i want to start with just
because it gets fun
um i want to read you just wrote this
piece on nikki haley
um so tim covers the right and the left
really well and and what this was the
lead for this piece
late last year nikki haley had a friend
who was going through a hard time
he had lost his job was being evicted
from his house he was getting bad advice
from bad people who were filling his
head with self-destructive fantasies
he seemed to be losing touch with
reality out of concern
haley called the man and said i want to
make sure you're okay
she told him you're my president but
you're also my friend
boom uh this is how tim wright sees the
world and kind of hooks you into his
pieces
so can you just tell me to start like
when you're writing a piece
and even and maybe there's probably a
difference between where you are now and
where you were as like a young
journalist but what is the
what is the goal that you're given from
the top what what are you incentivized
by that makes it
clicks headlines that kind of thing yeah
well there is a difference
uh certainly in in terms of
where you're at in your career zach i
mean there's
um you know there's no use in sugar
coating this
i think a lot of newsrooms now are sort
of operating around a model
in which you have a lot of uh sort of
younger less expensive less experienced
staffers whose job it is to
fill the website with sort of um clicky
material uh and you know a lot of it
through aggregation or kind of quick
twitch reporting or in some cases quick
twitch
analysis uh you know much of which winds
up being garbage but
uh that stuff is meant to sort of
churn the machine and feed the beast and
get eyeballs on the website which then
helps you get advertising dollars and
and revenue
and that revenue is what you use
then to funnel toward your
uh sort of upper echelon of reporting
you're more experienced
better paid
i don't want to say more talented
reporters but certainly your reporters
who are
sort of given a wider birth given a lot
more latitude
to spend you know a week or two
finding a story or maybe a month or two
finding a story uh there's obviously a
much
broader conversation to have about sort
of the transformation of media and how
you know when we were kids we're about
the same age when we were kids you know
magazines kind of ruled the landscape in
american media there were a lot of great
magazines with great
feature journalism a lot of long-form
work that you could sink your teeth into
that's not really the case so much
anymore a lot of
the the resources and the energy has
been sort of pushed toward the shorter
end of that spectrum
a lot of kind of quick hitting analysis
and aggregating of links and things like
that so
my my mandate in my current position
really is
is uh or in my current sort of phase of
my career
it's pretty wonderful because i don't
really have to worry a whole lot about
links
uh and and uh and clicks and eyeballs i
hope to get them obviously
but all i really try to do is tell great
stories i mean it's it sounds
it sounds simple and elementary because
it is but at the end of the day
i'm a big believer that you know if you
can tell
a really great story about a really
compelling subject matter
then uh people are going to read it you
know and um
and uh and for the most part i think
i've been successful
doing that and and really uh the
uh the burden often falls on
uh you know those reporters who are
younger and a little bit less
experienced
to do a lot of a lot of sort of
thankless work frankly and i feel just
really lucky to be at a place in my
career now where
i can stick my teeth into something for
a few months at a time and really work
it hard and not have to
not have to be swarmed by deadlines in a
way that i used to be
if you're not like an advent like an
active digester of news you're just
seeing a political headline you're
seeing at this headline you've seen this
headline
and to me there's not always an instant
process of who the author is
and sometimes on the website your work
of months and months and months
is equal on the website with someone who
did it in an hour
with you know ignoring a bunch of other
sorts of things like that like
how problematic is that what what is the
editorial process there and should those
incentives be more aligned from the
back end i mean look it's problematic to
me
because and i'm i'm super biased
obviously because if i've spent
uh six weeks reporting something and
then another few weeks
writing it and so you know the final
product finally publishes after two or
two and a half months of work
then yeah like i i want to see that
story
not only get sort of top billing on the
website but i want to see
all of the internal tools that my
publication has at its disposal
to be promoting and marketing that story
and you know to be fair
uh in the places i've worked they have
done that um i have i'm not
complaining that that it hasn't been
done but anybody who's
done that amount of work uh whether it's
a big investigative piece or a long form
profile that you've written of somebody
that's taken you a lot of man hours to
put together
when you've done that uh you have
inevitably as a reporter seen that piece
on the same day outshone uh
badly by some piece that somebody
put together in a half an hour uh and
they just sort of threw it online and
sometimes it's your own colleague it's
your own publication and it's not like
you begrudge them personally it's not
like you want to you know it's not like
you want to punch him in the nose or
anything
but yeah it annoys you of course it does
because it's like any
it's like any other line of work right
uh there there
there can be sort of an inverted
uh in incentive structure at times in
media right that
uh that that if you are faster
just uh sort of more in the moment and
more sort of snarky and and more you
know better able to sort of tap into the
zeitgeist of of of the topic or the day
then you're gonna have a better chance
maybe of getting mass
eyeballs on a story then uh if you are
just sort of approaching it in a more
traditional way so i mean that can
but but that spans industries i don't
know that that's something that's just
you know necessarily a plague in media
it strikes me that something that's like
needed or
missing in journalism and political
journalism maybe particular
particularly as we're talking about this
is like like a usda
style stamp of approval on certain
pieces
that have undergone a certain level of
rigor as opposed to others that haven't
and i'm like curious you know i watched
the newsroom if anybody seen like the
aaron sorkin like newsroom
show and you know there was all like
three sources for every fact you put on
there and they were like really militant
about it and you know
and i'm wondering like does that still
exist is there still like a set of
standards
industry-wide that are sort of agreed
upon and
whether or not they're slipping places
like is there a consensus among
journalists of like
this is how this should be vetted or or
done
it's a great question uh there's a lot
to unpack there
look i mean one of the things that i
love and again i'm super biased in this
conversation
guys part of my bias isn't just because
of what i do now but it's because of
what i've done in the past so like my
first job
full-time job in media was as a web
producer and it was
doing a lot of sort of aggregating of
links and
slapping quick headlines on a blog post
of 200 words
and putting a flashy headline on it and
getting it on social media as quickly as
possible
and again like there's i get why all
that stuff is necessary i
i'm not mad about any of it right but
there is an obvious
quality differential between
some of those sort of quick hitting
pieces that are meant to
as i said earlier just kind of feed the
beast get the eyeballs and create the
space needed to do that longer work
there's an obvious you know quality
disparity there um
it's interesting the way that you phrase
it carly as far as like
you know it should we be sort of
labeling like grade a
journalism versus grade d journalism
right like there's a difference between
eating at a really a really fine
steakhouse versus getting a steak
quesadilla at taco bell right
and like we know the quality of the beef
is different in those two places um
well the thing that you know going back
to my own bias the thing that i love
about magazine work uh and it's why i
was really privileged to work
at in the magazine section of politico
and it's why i'm so
uh excited to start at the atlantic soon
which is you know in my opinion the best
magazine in america
is magazine work tends to be subjected
to
a far greater amount of scrutiny in the
editorial process
so you have uh fact checking and
layers of editing on every story you're
writing in a magazine that just don't
exist in other parts of journalism
so and i really love that because i'm so
neurotic
and so anal about anything like if if i
find out that
i have a correction in a story of mine
it literally takes me three or four days
to stop being angry about like i take it
very personally
so the magazine process sort of lends
itself to that level of perfectionism
in a way that a lot of other sort of
digital journalism especially doesn't do
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle you got
high interest rates
resulting in minimum monthly payments
they just keep this vicious cycle going
of debt and upstart is here to help you
get ahead upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online so
whether it's paying credit cards
consolidated high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment and
unlike other lenders they don't just use
your credit scores why we like them they
use your income level your employment
history they look at all these different
data points in ai to give you a smarter
rate with trusted partners that fits
your world and debt level and you can
receive the funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
with like this five minute online rate
check so here's the deal find out how
upstart.com can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
slash yang that's upstart.com don't
forget to use our url
and tell them we sent you loan amount to
be determined based on your credit
income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
before i took the the job to work for
andrew someone said something
so interesting and um i think you'll
agree this one curious thoughts he said
to me
as i was leaving wall street said hey
just be careful with political
journalists because
in the business world so if you're a
business journalist you want to develop
a strong relationship with your source
because let's say you're finding a young
strong entrepreneur female the founders
of rent the runway these women are
badasses right
and you want to get to know them
highlight what they're doing but also
they're going to be successful for a
long time right so if you're a business
journalist
grow you know up and coming at xyz
outlet you want to develop a
relationship with them so then they
start their next company their next
company they have an empire you want to
have an in
and what he said to me the person who
told me they said i'm political
journalist you're going to have someone
who's right out of college
looking to shiv you because the way they
get their break
is not having a relationship was just
killing the politician
and in hindsight i found that to be true
um as a general hole like i didn't think
that a lot of journalists coming towards
me
there are exceptions and that's why
we're speaking tim i think you are an
exception there i think you were looking
at telling a great story and getting to
a virgin
um of objective truth but i think a lot
of them are just trying to write the
click bait
and screw you over most of the time what
are your thoughts there
you know so it's it's
it's a fair question and i think it's
really hard and it's not to give you a
cop out at all i think it's hard to
paint with a broad brush because
um are some journalists going to be sort
of unethical
and or lazy and just kind of look for a
quick kill on something
sure um but do some
uh subjects some candidates some
elected officials do they deserve to get
shipped
oh yeah oh you know what i mean oh my
god you're there because no one would
have done it yeah
that's what yeah and so like it's a
little tricky right because i think some
of this is in the eye of the beholder
and actually zach even even sort of
looking at the flip side of what you
just said i think that well yes there is
a
problem with some journalists who just
want to
do sort of hit and run coverage
that will um create sort of a bloody
spectacle that gets a lot of eyeballs
like i
i don't i don't disagree with that and
in some cases yes it's going to be
unwarranted and
could have been practiced better i think
that there's also on the flip side of
that same coin
a problem uh particularly with younger
reporters
who want to play the access journalism
game and who
uh and who want to be too friendly with
the people they cover
because they are looking at it through
sort of a long lens and saying look
this guy is going to be in congress for
years uh he's going to wind up chairing
this committee
uh his staff are they're going to you
know he might be in a leadership office
someday and his staff
uh there there are a bunch of you know
risers these are people who are going to
be running
the town one day i need to be in good
with them and so i'm going to really go
out of my way to never publish anything
negative or to really
sort of couch any criticisms into kind
of a broader critique of the institution
et cetera et cetera
so like and that's something that's
always you know been sort of
uh i think a problem in journalism as
well and so
uh you you have these things that are
uh i i think it's easy to diagnose
but really hard to solve right
practically speaking because
these are you know like and and look i'm
not perfect
i've made tons of mistakes in my career
and there's probably people who i've
taken it
much too easy on that in retrospect i i
should have been shiving
much earlier so it's you know it's it's
a tricky job and it's not to defend the
the institution as a whole uh the
industry as a whole because i think that
there are bad reporters the way that
there are bad teachers and bad cops and
and
you know bad uh you know members of
congress um
but by and large um i think that there
are
some really important questions uh the
likes of which you guys are asking right
now
that we need to grapple with uh in the
industry and i think
probably the biggest impediment to
grappling with them
is the fact that journalists tend to be
a little bit thin skinned and a little
bit
uh a little bit uh allergic to
self-criticism
and uh and i'm i'm again i'm guilty as
charged sometimes on on that very count
so it makes it hard to have the sort of
uh
introspective conversations that that
we're having right now
zach and i are somewhat cynical about
the state of journalism today and i i
think probably there's a number of yang
speaks listeners who
who feel that way people who are fans of
andrews who felt like he didn't always
get fair coverage on the presidential
campaign or
you know maybe now in various ways um
but i'd be curious
you know in the span of your career like
do you feel like there are areas where
journalism is better than ever like are
there places people should be looking
that
where the dynamics at play are actually
making things
better than they've ever been my um
educated guess as to why
some of the yang speaks listeners and
the math devotees uh the the the
folks who were you know really fervent
supporters of andrews during the
campaign the reason that they
uh had a bone to pick with uh
sort of mainstream media coverage of him
was because it was
oftentimes uh process oriented rather
than policy oriented and because it was
sort of focused on
uh horse race uh you know
and funneled through a a a filter of
like electability
and can he win and you know if not then
why does what he's saying matter
rather than what is he actually saying i
i felt you know and this is
obviously all my biases i'm totally
biased in this conversation but
i also felt like there wasn't an effort
equally across the candidates
to see the candidate from the
perspective of their supporters like i
felt like there was an it was like
things were inconsistently applied where
it was like
try and see yang through the eyes of a
yang supporter for instance instead of
sort of
through the eyes of you who may be an
elizabeth warren supporter and i felt
like
that was so plain in the way that things
were reported
and i found that frustrating it felt
like and you know maybe it's unfair
because i'm reading one journalist
talking about yang and a different
reporter who's talking about elizabeth
warren and i'm equating them in some
ways but
but that was part of what i felt like it
felt like there wasn't effort to be
to be generous which would be fine if
that was consistent but it didn't feel
consistent
what i'm hearing you say also is like
that there's not an effort
always to understand these people right
like
um and and what and what is motivating
them right and
and for me like that's a huge it's a
huge part of my job is when i say that i
want to tell good
stories well that's not just about like
pithy pithy
turns of phrase and like um you know
memorable anecdotes it's trying to
uh sort of peel away all of these layers
and get to
a place where you really as a reporter
really understand something that you
didn't understand
previously and then helping your readers
understand that right
so understanding the yang phenomenon
is a really important part of covering
the 2020 campaign
even if you don't think he's going to
win uh even if he's
you know even if by the traditional
metrics maybe he's not raising money
which of course he did raise money but
by any of these traditional metrics that
suggests you know that he's a long shot
well that's fine
and yet here's this guy who has no
background in politics
who has no political pedigree to speak
of
who is inspiring millions of people to
sit up and pay attention and get engaged
in a way that they had not been before
that in and of itself is fascinating and
and obviously very much worth a story
and
and and to my original point a minute
ago the critique of
political press being far
too process oriented and uh sort of
obsessive at times about the horse race
and and not focused enough
on the actual policy arguments and how
those policies are going to affect
people
i think it's a very fair critique my big
thing is guys
i think that we are constantly presented
with false choices here
like there's no reason that we can't
cover the horse race
and cover the process of electing a
president which is important in its own
right
and also cover the policy right because
these two things happen to intersect
quite a bit
and like as an example you know the
elizabeth warren people don't like me
very much because i was very harsh in my
coverage of her
has nothing to do with her personally
she ever any interaction i've ever had
with her
nice woman i don't have any personal
vendetta
um but i believe that the way she talked
about medicare for all
was completely insincere and and as a
policy matter
it was completely impracticable that it
was never going to become law
she knew that it wasn't going to become
law it was essentially the same as
trump promising that mexico was going to
that pay for the wall right this was
never going
to happen so from a policy standpoint
you know i i beat her up pretty good
right and and
and when it wasn't translating to votes
i beat her up a little bit more
basically making the point that i i felt
like voters were not rewarding
what they knew to be an unrealistic set
of
of policy promises um so there's a lot
there to sort of
digest but um i i believe that a lot of
these criticisms
are of the media are valid and and i
don't think we should be
shunning them at all we should be we
should be listening our first big
political event was called the wingding
in iowa
um it was in clear lake iowa
um this is a famous democratic political
event um
and this was two oh yeah 2018 says like
off year
it was us who knew but nobody knew um
john delaney
tim ryan and michael avenatti and
michael avenatti who is
um a famous race car driver very
successful his own right became a lawyer
and was stormy daniels
lawyer and stormy daniels is the porn
star who accused donald trump of a
number of things
um and there was all this hype around
mike avenatti
all this hype michael now he's gonna be
trump he's a bully yang yang did a good
job like
i can't say a great job i can't say
brought the house down because
i eventually saw him two years later
bring down the house at certain moments
um and so like comparatively not as
great but it was an early speech for him
it was solid and it was
definitely insightful interesting he got
us polite iowa standing oh but people
listened
for sure um he was one of the better
speakers of the night for sure
michael avenatti gets up there
everybody's supposed to be five minutes
delaney tim ryan we're five minutes
um avenatti goes for like 15 read from a
script
and was horrid like horrific i wish i
think you could find this on youtube
it's so
boring and so drunk
like didn't get the standing out like
nobody cared
um this guy was like any objective
person in that room is like this guy
isn't
gonna be president like he's like a
horrific public speaker um
the media swarmed him after and all
every single headline out of there
avenatti stars in the
fires up the democrats and i was like
this is just bs it's just a straight up
lie
and like the but my point was that the
piece had been written
before the event right like they were
ready like how often
probably when you're younger too maybe
or how often your colleagues like told
to go cover event but by the way you're
there for avenatti like you're there for
trump like what how often
because when things when the narrative
does change in real time i don't think
that gets covered and that was
frustrating for us in many ways
throughout the race this is us this is
zach and i just trying to uh
understand what happened on the on the
campaign and all these things we lived
through
this is therapy for us this is this is
this you're just here to talk us down
you know so like avenatti is a great
example right of here's this guy if you
went back and looked and i think that
there was a
there were a couple of uh of places that
did this that tallied his total number
of like cable news hits there for a few
months it was like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
cable news hits right yeah for this guy
who's a complete fraud a complete a
complete charlotte he's in jail by the
way
and has dm me from jail i can't wait to
show you from jail
okay it's the same story so andrew and
2019 was i think it was during the yang
media blackout was basically [ __ ] on
whatever the media establishment and
saying i was there when michael avenatti
was not very good
and michael avenatti responded and this
was after he went to jail for
nike fraud whatever he did in that deal
um he's in jail
and he tweets like you suck blah blah
blah and i retweeted him
say like is michael avenatti tweeting
from jail
and then he dm'd me and he's like he
like raged him you didn't
you're a boss yeah you're like you're a
bosses blah blah blah you suck like you
need to spend more time he's pulling at
one percent you suck like it was just
like dude why you talking i was nobody i
was like
yeah well so this is so he's a he's a
great example of this right
um nobody thinks that michael
avenatti is a serious person uh
nobody thinks that michael avenatti is a
particularly
uh you know ethical or upstanding person
somebody who like really deserves to
have a soapbox in the public square
but michael avenatti knew how to get
ratings
michael avenatti was gonna say a bunch
of crazy [ __ ] michael avenatti was going
to
uh be just as sort of flamboyant and
then
cindy and and as incendiary and um
kind of reckless rhetorically as trump
right and
so they're going to put them on the
airwaves uh and every reporter
who can get his number is going to text
him and try and get him in a story
i don't know that it's as prevalent as
you would think that
reporters are being sent to the event
saying hey
you know avenatti's going to speak be
ready
to write about him but i think that once
the event starts
uh for for a reporter in the room
who sort of uh has their own discretion
about what they're going to write
they want to get they want to get you
know clicks they want their
they want their story to gain traction
on social media
and if they just know from sort of the
buzz in the room
and from what other people are saying uh
before during and after the event
if they know that you know a headline
about michael avenatti
crashes the party and sets fire to trump
is going to get
more clicks than uh andrew yang uh
pitches a freedom dividend then that's
the story they're gonna write nine times
out of ten right like
here's a chicken in the egg question for
you guys right because i'm not trying to
um i'm not trying to dodge the bullet
here i think the media owns
some real culpability for this but
whether it's with the media
or with members of congress or with the
wall street collapse in 2008
like we can look at any of these
institutions and how they have failed
but how much of the blame belongs on the
consumer
right like how much how much fault lies
with the uh the the
the wall street firm that was uh over
leveraging
individuals and and setting them up with
bad loans versus how much blame belongs
to the individual
who over leveraged themselves and took
out a mortgage that they knew that they
couldn't afford well i would challenge
that though
is that is totally accurate until you
guys choose
not to cover not to cover it up right i
think i'm saying like
one thing we focused was like we know
that andrew yang is catnip
to me like when you do have these
dynamics right where you have bad
behavior on say the part of wall street
and you maybe
have uh there's a mix of culpability
between the consumer
and the the market actor that's to me
where you have kind of government to
step in or you have some sort of
regulation
i know very little about regulation in
like the journalism space
is there a place in your opinion for
regulation in this or
or no that just gets into really risky
territory well yeah look i mean the
first amendment is
as uh unequivocal as as it gets as far
as you know uh
what constraints we have in in the press
but that doesn't mean
so just because we're free from any sort
of official regulation
doesn't mean we're free from uh
accountability and and
um and you know listen
the the accountability needs to come
from within
that's that's the first line of defense
right is great editors
great newsroom leaders who can help uh
to make the editorial process as
rigorous
and transparent and accountable as as as
humanly possible right
and then i think that there's sort of a
secondary uh
layer of of self correction self
accountability uh from uh from from
within the media more broadly so from
outside of your individual newsroom
there are media reporters and media
ombudsmen
and people who are whose job it is from
within their own perch in the media
to hold media accountable right and
that's a really important
function that we should be playing and
that i think we don't really do well
enough
frankly and then i think to my point a
minute ago guys about the individual
responsibility versus the institutional
responsibility
um i think really the the the market
at a certain point has to speak for
itself readers
should be uh providing the sort of
accountability and viewers
should be providing the sort of
accountability uh that
dictates what we are producing right
so they shouldn't be booking michael
avenatti on cnn
you know 30 times in in 15 days right
but why
are they right because clearly their
their internal
data algorithms are showing them that
that traffic is spiking
and that people are tuning in and so
and and to me that's where there's a
real question about
sort of consumer habits and how do we uh
both as members of the media and as
consumers of news
like how do we help to fix this right
and like i'm just speaking for myself
i really try to reward
good journalism i try and spend my time
engaging
with journalism that's done right and
frankly i'm going to piss off some of my
friends by saying this but like
i don't watch cable news it's for the
most part i find it to be poison
and and what you put into your body is
important and what you put into your
mind is important
and if you want to watch out yeah like
if you want to watch um
you know i i have people ask me all the
time like friends family members like
well then where do you like if you're
watching tv
i said look if you if you need to get
your news from tv
watch your local nightly newscast on the
you know cbs affiliate or the fox
affiliate or whatever
or watch the pbs newshour with judy
woodruff and just get the facts
and then shut it off like you don't need
to stay up late into the night watching
cable news because
it's not really giving you much by way
of
useful objective journalism it's just
[Music]
not
all right i want to talk to you all
about better help i am a satisfied
customer of better help i talk to my
better help rep my therapist and we
talked about a whole bunch of things
mainly i'm just talking about the things
i don't talk about during the week which
is why i like it just an opportunity
to like let off a little steam in a
healthy way
where you're actually diving into the
things that are going on in that brain
and you can use better health to talk to
licensed professional counselors that
are specialized in depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
anger family conflicts you name it you
don't have to sit in the waiting room
it's secure it's online you can message
i can message sarah at any time it's
pretty cool and then we do
quick video calls it's amazing it's
convenient professional affordable
you're going to want to check this out
better help is awesome so i want you to
start living a happier life today do
what i just did and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com so check out
what over 1 million people have done
and take in charge of their mental
health by using betterhelp that's
dot betterhelphelp.com slash yang
[Music]
so this is the attention economy right
what you're doing is like we're all
everyone's competing for your attention
um and
there's some sort of political
legitimacy to
someone's name being on tv or in the
headline all day long i mean it happened
it's happened with trump where it's like
most people aren't paying attention
because there's so many things going on
and so trump's in the headlines all day
long what's your natural reaction if
you're not paying attention
trump must be the frontrunner for
president or must be a serious contender
and that's how it works
and there was a moment we had it was a
basically two years after
the avenatti moment i had where um
it was right after the houston debate
where we had done our like debate
giveaway gimmick to become a thing
and our plan was to show a show of force
in iowa that we weren't just this like
hey like attention grabber and
with our thousands a month but we were a
serious contender we were going to go to
we did yangapalooza in
iowa we had a thousand people come from
all over can we laugh at the fact that
we're like we're a serious contender
i think pretty well but to the press was
like this is a big and yang did a
different speech
he called it kids are not all right one
of his most watched speeches um
and it was a very different message and
the press that night was very
disheartening was we were just not even
mentioned we weren't mentioning like the
roundups like we just got nothing
and part of that is i think on us where
we had um
didn't have the same comms relationships
with reporters
but there was also part of that like the
media had
there were certain people they wanted to
cover or decided to cover or that sort
of thing and i'm curious
ignore yang like is that that's not the
point um
my bigger point is what is decided to
cover
from your end you're being like the
collective media collective you
um ends up in some ways dictating who we
think
should win um in its own way and i'm
curious of it's the media's impact
on like this chicken head problem like
the media's impact on
our policy and our political parties and
that kind of thing like thoughts on how
you feel like either you or your
colleagues get to shape the narrative
in terms of serious political contenders
what do you think yeah so
look there's a uh there's kind of an
age-old uh
divide in in terms of how candidates
can get their message out to the masses
right and you guys know this obviously
from having worked on on the campaign
but there's free media and
there's paid media right and sometimes
free media is also known as earned media
uh now now whether when you're talking
about
free media uh you know it's funny
because
traditionally it has been synonymous
with earned media
which essentially means that you're
hustling and you're doing something to
get
you know cnn to carry your speech or
you're doing something to get
politico out on the trail with you
covering you writing about you whatever
you're doing something to get the new
york times editorial board writing
something about your campaign right
now what's what's interesting to me is
that
whereas just to finish the thought there
whereas on the other side
paid media is advertising right so
that's the that's the distinction on one
side it's
paid media which is andrew yang going up
on tv with 30 second spots and
explaining his plan for health care or
for
the freedom dividend or whatever the
case may be versus
the paid slash earned media is hey this
guy is doing something really
interesting
let's send somebody out to new hampshire
with him for a couple of days and write
a story about
the groundswell of college students who
are coming out to yang rallies right
what's interesting to me is that in 2016
with the trump campaign the line
really began to sort of blur between
free
and earned media and i guess what i mean
by that is that they no longer really
felt synonymous
that trump actually wasn't doing all
that much to earn the media coverage he
was getting
he was just getting it for free because
he was a circus freak
right i mean he he was trump was the
bearded lady
and everybody wanted to see him and
we knew that and look you're talking to
a guy who
uh for the first i want to say for the
first four or five
months of that 2016 presidential cycle
uh and i was
you know a uh senior correspondent for
the national journal covering that
campaign
i didn't write his name or or if i did
it was like in a fleeting
after thought sarcastic sentence i
didn't write anything about the guy
because i just refused to give it oxygen
i thought it was sort of a joke right
and then eventually his poll numbers
rise to the point where he's
at the top of the heap and he's standing
center stage at the debates and then
you're
forced to cover him right like you can't
you can't not cover
but it's it's in that period from you
know june
through uh october say where
he's just getting round the clock media
coverage and it's often times for doing
nothing he's sitting in his penthouse
tweeting something crazy about like
oprah or about
you know megyn kelly or about um rosie
o'donnell
and it's getting saturation news
coverage
and uh you know that's that's where
i'm sort of looking around saying wait a
second this isn't right like
this is this is not this is not a
healthy way for media to operate and i
think the thing is guys
without you know preaching at anybody
here i think a lot of
folks in media looking back now
they have regrets about the way they
handled trump uh in 2016
and a few a few people have actually
said as much publicly
uh but i also think that those same
people especially on the television side
of things
this has been the most remarkable run
for them financially and ratings wise
that they've ever had
you know and so and so how bad do they
really feel about it because
this has been sort of a golden era for
them and and and it's a really hard
thing to sort of grapple with
the fact the fact that on the one hand
we probably did not
operate we the media did not operate in
a
in a really respectable ethical way in
covering trump's rise
um and yet uh trump has been
just incredibly lucrative for the media
industry on the whole
well there's there's been public like
documentation now right of the
relationship between
the what is it like ceo owner of cnn
and trump and i think this this yeah
clearly
put off sort of a downward trend for
cable news and a lot like kind of gave
them a lifeline for
for a few years uh i mean i do have
thoughts on on where cable news goes
from here
sort of without trump
boy i mean the great quote that comes to
mind was
um les les moonves from
cbs who uh he said
very famously a couple of years ago
talking about their coverage of trump
talking about the media's coverage of
trump
he said it wasn't good for america but
it was darn good for cbs
right and like that that puts a pretty
pretty good bow on this conversation
you know for me um
what i would find interesting is the
sort of thing that you're probably never
going to get because it would put a lot
of people to sleep but like i i
the the little bit of cable news that
i'll consume here and there
is when you can put three or four really
smart really well-sourced journalists at
a table
and have them sort of empty out their
notebooks and and talk really
sort of analytically about uh a given
policy debate on the hill
you know healthcare or immigration or
you know the stimulus bill something
like that right like something that
actually
educates people uh and informs people
and rather than just entertaining people
uh you know i but look you got to be
realistic again
much of the enter much of the news
business especially
the news business after dark it is an
entertainment business right these guys
are
you know tucker carlson is an
entertainer he's not a journalist right
and and
and by the way he's a really good
entertainer he gets a ton of eyeballs he
knows
he even though i think he's sort of a
despicable human being he
he knows how to get people to tune into
his show
right and and that's the hallmark of a
great entertainer this is what always
makes me laugh
when you have people like tucker carlson
you have the
folks on the right uh are always very
like angry
that hollywood celebrities have a
political opinions
and i'm like why are they less qualified
than you like
sean hannity is like less formally
educated than natalie portman like do
like and and they are entertainers
they're political entertainers and to
have
certain people who have like no
political background themselves
political commentators yelling at the
fact that like natalie portman has an
opinion
is such a bizarre and kind of just like
such a hypocritical funny thing to me
because
to your point like clearly you are an
entertainer like that
is that it's your position in this
ecosystem god bless you for saying that
because it's
it's exactly it's exactly right i mean
look the the difference between
natalie portman and sean hannity is that
you know
she poses on the red carpet uh in front
of
a um you know uh in front of a
planned parenthood gala and sean hannity
poses on the red carpet
in front of an nra gamer like that's
that's the only difference right
but they have they have very they have
very similar professions
they are paid to entertain people at the
end of the day that's all it is and i
feel bad in a way because i do know
some people who work at the the big
three fox and cnn and msnbc who
are real journalists and who are good
people and some of whom are friends of
mine and i like
but i will say this to their face like
that your
networks are like contributing to the
decline of american civilization right
and like we have to do something about
this
and i don't think that there's
necessarily a big appetite to do a lot
about it
all right mother's day is around the
corner and i bet if you're listening
this
you haven't gotten a gift yet but don't
worry we're gonna cover your ass
literally because i want to talk about
hello tushy's brand new 3.0 modern bidet
yes we are still doing bidet ads on this
podcast because of there's so
many good reasons to be using a bidet it
cuts down with toilet paper costs
they're easy to install
this new hello tushy 3.0 bidet cleans
itself with the smart spray
automatic self-cleaning nozzle this
thing attaches to your existing toilet
no electricity no tech support face
times
nothing and it cuts your toilet paper
used by 80 percent which can get
expensive
so literally the hello toshi bidet pays
for itself in a few months plus
there's a 60-day risk-free guarantee and
a 12-month
warranty so give the gift of a clean
butt go to hellotushy.com
yang to get 10 off plus free shipping
this is a special offer
for our listeners around mother's day at
hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off hello hellotushy.com
[Music]
right now we have um two political
parties that are lost and it's mainly
it could be because of our media
companies and institutions right now we
have the republicans on the far right
are
just anti-democrat essentially and you
have democrats that aren't really sure
of what
being a democrat fully means and that's
a very like simplistic way of saying it
but i do think both parties are very
lost
and i think media has a part of that
where do you think they go where do we
land 10 years from now in terms of our
political parties and is the media going
to continue
shaping them do they eventually buck the
trend and it goes different direction
what do you what do you think in there
you know when we talk about
institutional decline in america and and
i
talk about it a lot uh because it's i i
think sort of the great
story of our time is the the public's
loss of confidence in
these core pillars of society right
whether you're talking about
law enforcement or public education or
the media
or organized religion we don't often
think about
political parties as institutions and we
really need to
right because political parties
uh the world over especially in liberal
democracies
when you have strong political parties
you tend to have
strong and stable countries when you
have weak
political parties you tend to have very
uh disrupted and
and disorganized and chaotic countries
uh
and and what we've seen over the last
i would say uh five to ten years and
probably even take it back a little bit
further maybe say last
10 to 15 years is a sort of
asymmetric assault on the institution of
political parties in this country
and you know when we talk about donald
trump
i often will bring bernie sanders into
the same conversation
not because they believe in the same
things but because
they represent in many ways sort of
opposite sides of the same problem which
is that
you know in 2016 the two candidates who
did the most to energize their party
bases
donald trump and bernie sanders they had
never belonged to those parties
right donald trump had never been a
republican bernie sanders had never been
a democrat
and it's not it's not as though these
institutions should be
above reproach and that and that they
should be sort of insulated from the
sort of pressure that a donald trump
uh exerted on the republicans or bernie
sanders exerted on the democrats
it's that when they were sort of stress
tested
those parties did not respond well to
the stress test and particularly on the
republican side
the party just collapsed entirely right
like a
i've said this a hundred times guys and
i wrote about this quite a lot in my
book
uh which i will shamelessly plug i was
gonna say plug it yeah right over my
shoulder american carnage
the book was in large part about the
institutional
unraveling of the republican party
because donald trump
could not have hijacked a strong
republican party he it just he he would
not have been able to take over
a strong republican party would not have
happened um what happened was
the party had sort of become so
institutionally weakened
uh by the bush presidency by americans
loss of confidence
in uh the republicans ability to govern
and
and the tea party wave sort of
decimating the the
what vestige remained of the
establishment in the gop
uh that sort of had the ability to uh
hold
the line and sort of keep the gate and
determine who gets in the party and who
stays out
right like we all we all sort of in a
vacuum
love to hate the smoke-filled room and
the good old boys network and the gray
beards in the party establishment but
actually
like there's something to be said for
the party establishment there's
something to be said for
the smoke-filled room there's something
to be said for this idea that there are
people
who are gatekeepers who can expel a
marjorie taylor green
or a steve king or some of these
radicals from a party and say no
you do not belong here we don't want you
in our club right
you've similarly on the left seen this
sort of continued stress
testing of the democratic party and i
don't think that
uh had i don't think had the imperative
been
uh so universally felt among democrats
to get trump out of office
uh and that obviously leading to joe
biden
emerging as just this sort of consensus
candidate right
i don't think that uh had those
circumstances been different
we may have seen the same sort of thing
happen in the democratic party in 2020
you might have seen
just a complete collapse of the party
establishment and you might have seen
a bernie sanders get nominated hell you
could have even seen andrew yang get
nominated
you you could have seen just the sort of
complete
uh uh sort of demise of the
old system that sort of had held up for
so long
and i'm not again i'm not necessarily
saying that that would be a bad thing
as long as something that can take its
place
in a way that sort of serves the country
in a functional and healthy way and
clearly what's happened to the
republican party over the last five to
ten years is not functional it is not
healthy
and the party is sort of desperate for
a sort of renaissance like the liz
cheney wing the adam
kinziger wing of the party is really
trying to stand back
up something that can function
as a traditional uh strong party
establishment but it's gonna be really
hard for them guys and your question is
about where does this go
moving forward i think the challenge is
on the one side republicans trying to
stand that thing back up
and on the democratic side it's trying
to keep it up it's trying to hold
hold the line and not get sort of bowled
over uh
as has happened to the republicans you
say that institutional
collapse you mentioned like the bush
presidency and kind of a failure of
governance
but is there also an element of of just
that party establishment and elite
getting out of step and
out of touch with like everyday
americans is that fundamentally what
weakens them to the point of
of collapse totally it's a great yes
it's an absolutely
essential part of this conversation
because and again this is where
this is not black and white what we're
dealing with right this is a complicated
nuanced conversation that has to be had
so there's a really fine line right
between
donald trump actually doing something
that was really helpful
and productive which was kind of shining
a light on the intellectual complacency
of the post reagan republican party
right
a party that had come to believe that if
it was good for wall street
and if it was good for the heritage
foundation then it must be good for the
american people right
and actually along comes trump who
after decades of living in his gilded
penthouse suite in manhattan
somehow had a better thumb on the pulse
of
the working class american than did
anybody
else in the party right which is kind of
the the great
irony of the trump era but look give him
credit to a certain degree because
here was a guy who said listen all of
your constituents
they hate you and do you know why they
hate you because
you're a bunch of elitist snobs who look
down your noses at these people
and you have no appreciation for the way
that they live their lives and
furthermore you have no appreciation for
how their lives
have been completely upended by forces
of technology and globalism and
everything else right
and so there's a fine line between what
trump did
to sort of call attention to these
things which was
way overdue and really needed to happen
versus
trump becoming a xenophobic race-baiting
bigot
uh who was sort of channeling the
darkest impulses of these angry people
and using it in a really destructive way
so like the flip side
of that right is look at andrew yang for
example right
there andrew yang calling attention to
income inequality i've grown up around
people who
whose jobs at the ford plan and at the
gm
plant and at the supplying companies
have gone away
and they've spent their adult years
waiting tables at chili's because of it
right like
this is something that they've had to
grapple with that their entire
communities have had to grapple with
that
good friends of mine have had to grapple
with and so andrew yang calling
attention to the menace of automation
and how it has already begun to decimate
the workforce and how
if uh it continues on a you know on a
similar trajectory moving forward
that we are going to be as a country
reckoning with
the sort of mass unemployment crisis
that we've never really seen before
uh that's a really i think a good thing
a good conversation that needs to be had
now where andrew yang to sort of take
that
and then cross over into a much darker
place
and use uh the attention that he has
gained from this first thing
to uh to and sort of channel it into a
very
negative very ugly very destructive and
divisive
uh place then i think that would be the
bad side of it right
and so again it's there's sort of a a
a good side to populism and a very very
dark side to populism looking at this
landscape right now and where it's going
both politically both media with it um
it's two questions for you what excites
you and what scares you what
encourages me and discourages me uh
is almost in some cases the same thing
or there's just
like a very very thin line dividing them
i think you know what encourages me is
that we have more ways to reach voters
uh and reach readers reach citizens than
ever before
and that's cool um but what discourages
me is that some of those ways that we
reach people
uh it encourages really uh crappy sloppy
substandard journalism right
so like that's an example like there's a
very thin line there there's another
very thin line between
sort of the the the financial state of
journalism
so there's never been more money pouring
into places like
the new york times or the washington
post or cnn
or the atlantic um but these
sort of big national organizations their
footprint is growing by the day and
because of it they can afford to hire
great reporters
to do great work and that's a good thing
uh at the same time
there's never been a bleaker financial
situation
facing uh small and mid-sized
and even larger traditionally larger
local
print publications major metro daily
newspapers
have shriveled up from coast to coast
they are a shell of their former selves
they are shrinking literally by the week
their advertising dollars have
evaporated
their subscription revenue models are
not very good
in in most cases and it's a terrible
terrible thing
to think about living in a community
that does not have a robust staff
of experienced reporters who can get out
there into the community and hold people
accountable and inform the local
citizenry and by the way guys this is
all interconnected right because
when you when you no longer have a
strong
local news presence to inform you then
what are you going to turn to
you're going to turn on fox news right
you're going to turn on cnn
uh and and to me that's that's really
problematic
uh so i think what above all what
encourages me
is that um you know you you do have
i think a more engaged
uh electorate a more engaged
readership viewership a more engaged
american
public uh on some of these big issues
than we've had in a really long time
right uh because you have
the sort of intersection of um
you know of trumpism and of covid
and of mass you know economic uh
disruption
and um you know there's there's just a
lot happening in this country right now
and so i think because of that
you have a lot of people just just
you know starved for information and
they're then they're and they're coming
to places like the atlantic
like politico like the new york times
like the washington post to get it and
that's good right
i think the thing that worries me the
most is just i want to make sure
that that information they're getting is
good and reliable
and uh and and produced in a way
that meets a certain set of usda
standards to carly's point earlier
uh without you know without actually
having that stamp of approval because
that's just you know um
as hot as as blue skies as we might want
to be about it
you know it's just probably never going
to happen you're you're never going to
have some way of
really uh regulating media in that way
uh and that's why the regulation has to
come from within
right we have to do a better job of
making sure that that information
is really top quality my prediction and
carly i'm curious your thoughts on this
too my prediction is that is
as we start we stop to trust
institutions we're going to start to
trust
people to fill that void and it's why
podcasts have grown and it's why
um some of these longer forms why the
the atlantic is able to
frankly is pouring money into hiring
people like yourself um and that people
are going to flock towards talent and
the trust will be in that human
which is a little scary at times um but
there's also
a certain level of that trust is earned
in in some ways too and i hope that when
people know that we're coming on this
podcast they know like there's a certain
point that
if we're accused of of lying or being
dishonest that you've listened enough
and
grown enough with us that you hopefully
know and feel in your heart that we
never do that and that's kind of the
trust is like well i know fox would
never do that that's not true
but i know tim alberto would never do
that because i've gotten to know him as
a human and that's why i trust him i
feel like that
is probably where this starts to go
until we can start get institutions and
maybe you start to see
publications like the atlantic like hire
enough tim's and enough
isaac dovers or people that i love
reading there that are writing stuff
that you know has been
fact-checked and sourced well and and
researched and well thought out
carly what do you think on that i don't
know your thoughts on the future where
this goes given
basically yeah i i have so many thoughts
on this as a as you kind of know
i definitely agree that there's a move
towards individuals i think sub stack is
proof of that i look personally i've
said this actually i think publicly
before
i don't read a lot of call it
institutional journalism i read a lot of
sub stack i have certain trusted people
who
who i really use as my filter through
kind of different subject matters
um and i do think that's a rising trend
and it plays into this
broader trend you were talking about tim
of sort of a collapse of institutions
um and we spoke the other day to uh this
esports
individual and and we talked about how
even
even on the purely entertainment side of
things you see the younger generation
moving away from disney channel and on
to
like twitch streams and youtube shows
where it feels more raw and you're
building this personal relationship
with an individual content creator not a
you know not a machine that's creating
content
so i think you're seeing this happen
across
really a number of different industries
where people are now drawn more to
individuals and individual voices that
they're getting to know
through you know social media and the
internet and whatever else rather than
these sort of
standard industry machines so i i
absolutely think that's that's a
direction
and look you know um and it's not like
the media would be an outlier in that
respect uh because
you know people distrust
uh you know uh the american health care
system right but they trust their own
doctor um
people don't hate congress they like
their congressmen yeah exactly but
they keep voting for their congressman
to go back right it's um
you know they don't trust uh wall street
but they like their financial advisor
so um i i think the trick though for
media in particular
is to is to you know
we're told all the time that we are our
own
brands right now more than ever because
of the internet because of social media
that we are
our own brands and i think that's true
but i am really a big believer in the
institution of media and
in these organizations needing to have
great credibility and so i've always
really tried to
uh tie my brand in with the brand that i
am working for not just to be a good
like employee but to make sure that
um i i it's just sort of a you know
rising tide belief that like
at the end of the day um
it's cool if people trust my byline and
if they come to my stories because they
like the stuff i do and they know that
they can trust me
but i want them to feel that way about
uh you know any
major news organization like i spent a
couple years ago
i spent a few days inside the des moines
register
newsroom and i wrote a feature story
about how this
once great american newspaper that had
like hundreds and hundreds of employees
and published a newspaper that thick
seven days a week has now just sort of
shriveled into
this you know ghost of what it once was
and
all of the sort of cultural and economic
and civic implications of that right
and it's it it was like i gotta tell you
honestly without being melodramatic it
was like one of the saddest stories i
ever wrote
because not just because i'm a
journalist but because
i grew up every day uh in in metro
detroit
and came downstairs to my breakfast
table and there was a copy of the
detroit news and a
copy of the detroit free press and that
was like that was my big part of my life
it's like my brothers and i would like
fight over the sports section and then
whoever didn't get the sports section
you know they'd go to the the comics or
the metro page or whatever
like that was but like and my parents
would sit there leisurely on the you
know and
leafing through like that's a big part
of civic life to me
and um and so it's not just about you
know the people doing sub stack
i don't hold it against them at all like
more power to you find a way to inform
the public i get it
but i feel like a personal investment in
in these organizations and in this
institution as a whole
that goes beyond just you know my byline
i think
i can be very cynical about to use the
word you used earlier which i use
gatekeepers like i and and you know
again maybe partly this is
the chip on my shoulder i still have
from andrew yang's campaign feeling like
the gatekeepers didn't like us so much
but
i think you make a strong case that you
need a balance right like you need
the gatekeepers are not in some cases
can be
good and powerful and needed and it
seems like you're kind of making a
similar case here to some extent right
like
gatekeepers institutions whatever you
want to call them like having strong
functioning institutions actually is a
powerful thing
and a hallmark of like a thriving
successful
nation in some ways and um so i think
it's alarming that
that they are collapsing the way they
are ideally
we can fight hard enough so that they
evolve and not
completely collapse because of their to
your point in their influence
on certain aspects of society and it's
um
andrea always talked about it's either
star trek or mad max and
um i feel like the me me situation is
probably more
mad max than star trek which is the
mindset of abundance
so tim this was fascinating let me so
your book american carnage i'll put a
link in
um but the other piece is like i'm just
so curious
and you're probably not allowed to tell
me so it you know i will put you on
you don't have to answer this question
but if you can i'm curious first
story at the atlantic where are you
going where's your head going what's
your thought what's your thought process
you know uh uh it is uh
uh top top secret confidential
information uh that i would have to kill
you if i told you
but let me i'll say this um
you know we've talked about political
media and and i've spent you know last
15 years of my life uh
covering politics and a big reason for
my move uh to the atlantic is to
step away from politics and and really
try and tell some stories about those
other institutions that we've been
talking about
my my my sort of overarching goal
here moving to the atlantic is to is to
ask
some of these very fundamental questions
about like how do we hold this thing
together as a country like
you know because there there are
some just deep fractures in american
society right now that are not going to
heal on their own
and and actually uh they might get much
deeper
and if they get much deeper then i think
we're gonna be in trouble quite honestly
and um
and so i really want to look at you know
organized religion in this country i i
really want to look at
public education in this country i
really want to try and uh tell
stories about rural america and
and um you know everything from uh
you know the the sort of small town
diner that's become
mythologized to uh you know the the
the city uh schools that have uh let
kids down i mean there's
there's there's a lot to get into here
and um
i and i'm really excited that they're
going to give me the latitude i want to
to go out and find those stories and
tell them so
i can't get real specific but i've got a
couple of big ones coming right off the
bat that i'm excited about
that's all that is healthy and look i
think i will say this um
i believe now having seen the inner
workings of politics and media in the
united states
i think if you can either be in that
space
as an outsider coming in like come from
somewhere else and get into it
or be in that space and get out being in
politics media offers so much
perspective on
almost how the whole world works and
particularly how a whole country works
and i think it is really powerful
and important for people to be outside
of that space and get in and then come
out and help
or help within or be in there and come
out and take that perspective elsewhere
so um i'm so excited for you i am
grateful for you for taking your time
tim
thank you best of luck in the new role
and we must be happy to
wait to read your uh your future pieces
tim thanks guys well you're you're very
you're very kind for having me
and uh hope hope you and your loved ones
are staying healthy and hanging in there
back at you
[Music]
you